a new report by USA Today raises
concerns about mental health risks
linked to high potency marijuana
products and the potential for psychotic
episodes Jamie yuccas is in our Los
Angeles Bureau Jamie what evidence did
USA Today look at well Anthony the
papers spoke with medical professionals
and a dozen parents whose children
suffered mental breakdowns it focused on
high potency THC products like vapes and
oils and some children died by suicide
or had suicidal thoughts I woke up in a
mental hospital I never thought I was
going to be there ever
Madison McIntosh says less than a year
ago he started vaping high potency THC
after his lifelong dream to play
professional baseball hit a dead end he
says he used THC to get him out of his
depression in reality was actually just
putting me even more so in the hole of
depression and unhappiness the 24 year
old says it got to the point where he
was vaping multiple times a day up until
March that's when his boss called his
dad and stepmom to say Madison was
acting strangely I started to talk with
him and within 30 seconds I knew
something was wrong like he was out of
his mind
Madison's older brother took this cell
phone video that night
what is the noise my brain
at the hospital Madison's parents say
doctors diagnosed him with cannabis
induced psychosis I grew up in the 70s
early 80s you never heard of cannabis
induced psychosis what is that I looked
at a kid who had everything going for
him and I had to stare at him sitting on
a hospital bed with a sheet and a pillow
in this room stark white jane O'Donnell
co-authored the USA Today article titled
in part is marijuana linked to psychosis
in the 1980's the marijuana that anybody
that smoked marijuana was using often
had far less than even 10 percent THC
content it is very common for people to
be smoking something with 90% THC
content now the article cites one study
that found a 77 percent increase in
suicide deaths in Colorado among 10 to
19 year olds with marijuana in their
systems is not clear and may never be
clear whether cannabis caused a person
to have psycho affective disorders there
certainly is a link between the heavy
cannabis use and the schizophrenia or
the psychosis and it certainly made
worse UCLA professor Timothy Fong is an
addiction specialist who studies
cannabis he says while more research is
needed in some severe cases cannabis can
be linked to psychosis but for the vast
majority of men and women who use
cannabis in a adult fashion in a
reasonable manner and who obtain
cannabis from a regulated and legal
dispensary those risks are fairly low
now we reached out to several marijuana
advocacy groups for their response to
the article the group called normal told
us cannabis should not be viewed as a
harmless substance it says because it
may pose certain health risks to
potentially vulnerable populations it
should be regulated to keep it away from
those who may be at higher risk for
experiencing an adverse reaction
Anthony all right Jimmy thanks